We can detect planets outside our solar
system by the gravitational effects
that these planets have on their stars.
Small planets, like earth,
weigh much less than their star.
When those planets move in their
orbits, the effect on the star
is very hard to see.
The force they exert on each
other is comparatively small.
So the star barely moves as
the planet orbits around it.
Large planets, like Jupiter, have
a greater gravitational influence
on their star.
But when the planets are far away,
the effect is still fairly small.
The planet and star are
orbiting a common centerpoint,
but it's close to the
center of the star.
However, we found planets
that are larger than Jupiter,
and which orbit much closer to their
star than Jupiter is to our sun.
The effect of gravity is
much stronger in these cases.
With such large planets, it's easier to
see that the planet's gravity affects
the star's motion, and that
the two orbit a common center.
We can't see the star
move back and forth,
because the stars are very, very,
very, very far away from us.
Instead we use the Doppler
effect, the same effect
that causes sound to change
pitch when it's source moves.
When a source of waves moves towards
us, we here it as higher pitched.
When the wave source moves away
from us, we hear a lower pitch.
In terms of light
frequency, that corresponds
to light moving more towards
blue, higher frequency.
Or more towards red, lower frequency.
The effect is small, so we don't
see it in our day to day lives.
But we can detect it
with a spectrometer.
As the exoplanet moves away from
us, the star comes towards us.
So the light becomes ever
so slightly more blue.
On the other side of the orbit,
as the star moves away from us,
the light from the star
becomes slightly more red.
The amount of shift, the
difference from blue to red light,
tells us how fast the star is moving.
That, in turn, tells us whether we
have a light planet, a medium planet,
or a heavy planet affecting
the movement of the star.
And that's the wobble method.
-It's supposed to be spinning.
That's true.
That's one thing we don't have
right in this, is it's not spinning.
OK, when you're ready.